course plotted October 17th 1975 time
trap cool the future of the world is in
your hands I like killing people here
it's a dick let's go spark a doobie
I'm a Time Master making discrete
alterations to the timeline is what I do
you people please stop hitting
hey youtubers is charlie sonu Roland
papers legends of tomorrow trailer who
knew Martin Stein like the blaze so much
now as hilarious as it is to think about
the white canary going to blaze up with
young Martin Stein in the 70s you notice
that there at Ivy University which is a
huge location in the firestorm and the
atom comics now obviously the Ray Palmer
is a more contemporary version on the
show he's not really associated with Ivy
University quite as much as he is in the
comics but he was actually one of Ronnie
Raymond's professors now here like
because they have Victor Garber they
just tied him to Ivy University more
than they have the atom the atom inside
this like arrow flash universe is a
little bit closer to the Blue Beetle
character to the Ted Kord character
that's who he was originally intended to
be actually but as much as they have all
these really awesome super-powered
characters in the show they're gonna do
this big special effects Victor Garber
is like their secret weapon normally you
think it'd be harder for genre shows
like this especially shows on smaller
networks playing actors that are that
accomplished like I was really surprised
when Tom Cavanagh signed on to the flat
now obviously the flash turned into this
amazing show so now it's not a surprise
at all but part of the reason they were
able to get Victor Garber is because he
previously worked on a bunch of Greg
Berlanti shows same thing with Tom
Cavanagh they'd all worked together
previously like Marc Guggenheim like all
the producers all the people behind the
scenes and the people on camera had
worked together on previous shows so
anytime they change like little tidbits
about Martin Stein from the comics I
totally don't mind because some of those
actors are so amazing Victor Garber
scenes with Cisco or some of the best in
the flash Martin Stein was the character
that they gave the multiverse explainer
to at the beginning of the flash season
this year multiple versions of our earth
some with things that are a little bit
different somewhat things that are
wildly different fun fact there was
actually a scene from the pilot that
they cut out and then use much later the
first time we saw Martin Stein on the
train that was a scene that they shop
for the pilot but then removed just
because they felt it worked better in a
different episode originally after the
two-part episode of arrow that
introduced the Barry Allen character the
story was is that he took the train home
so you can kind of see early on that the
flash was always planning to do the
firestorm character and they had cast
Victor Garber really early on really the
biggest change that I can think of two
legends of tomorrow in terms of the cast
is the hawk bank character originally
they didn't know if they were going to
do Carter Hall not that it was last
minute or anything I mean they decided
pretty early on they wanted it to be a
team-up show like
decided they wanted Hawkman then it
became legends of tomorrow it was still
like a hawk girl Hawkman show before it
was a team-up show Stevie which part of
the reason why they made it a team-up
shows because they wanted to go even
bigger than the flash I know a lot of
people have been wondering like what
happens if arrow goes off the air after
five seasons because to my knowledge the
actors have not been signed past season
five the actors on arrow really that
could change at any time in Marc
Guggenheim the show Verner said that the
show will continue as long as Stephen
Amell wants to continue making it which
just means that they'll just keep going
until they don't want to do it anymore
but the question then becomes what would
be like the next biggest thing they
could do after legends of tomorrow like
if the CW wanted another superhero show
to fill the hole left by arrows absence
before they made the big Suicide Squad
movie announcement I would have said a
Suicide Squad show would have been
something they could totally pull off
but because they're turning it into a
big movie franchise they had to kind of
kill off the dead shot character on the
TV show not going to do a whole lot of
Suicide Squad episodes but they could
totally do a rogue's TV show or a
firestorm TV show I think it'd be a
little bit easier for them to do a rogue
show just because they could rotate the
cast a little bit more and it's really
expensive to do firestorm visual effects
all the time that's why you haven't seen
firestorm quite as much so that's
actually good question for you guys let
me know in the comments in a couple
years when it gets time to figure out
whether or not they're going to keep
doing arrow or they're going to cancel
it which characters that they've already
established do you want them to create a
new spin-off for to fill that hole so
they still have their three shows on the
air for my money they just they spent
the most amount of time developing rogue
characters it just it makes sense that
they would do a rogue team up show
speaking of big team ups though I'm
gonna do like a short video for it on
Facebook but if you guys didn't see MTV
just premiered shannara chronicles'
starring Manu Bennett who was
Deathstroke and azog from The Hobbit
movies so you should definitely check
that out it's on MTV I think they'll
play it in their web player if you
missed it on air but I've also got some
new Star Wars that I'm going to do for
tomorrow so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner progenitor please
private message me on the back end of my
channel swing get your contact info I've
already started a new round this week
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's real simple just in case you
guys haven't seen it i posted a video
earlier today all about daredevil season
2 dropping on the exact same day that
Batman
Superman is coming so it'll be like
marvel vs DC you can click here to learn
all about that battle royale and you can
click here to learn all about death
storm coming to the flash season 2 thank
you so much for watching everybody the
set 5 i'll see you guys tonight